Speaker 1: Let's go next to Tim from
Wisconsin. Tim, you were on the air next.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Excellent. Um, let's see,
I guess I'm a little bit concerned with the school
boards lately where you keep on seeing these
threats of violence. Is there a threshold in
your mind that we really need to be, you know,
taking some defensive action or doing something?
Speaker 1: What do you mean you're saying like
security at school board meetings?
Or do you mean political defense?
Speaker 3: More physical like security.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, that's it,
we're probably already past that threshold, to
be totally honest. I think that there are some
places that have gone to closed school
board meetings. They've eliminated this like
audience commentary portion to make it safer.
But I think we're already there and you know,
it really varies. It depends on the school
district, but I think we're already at the point
where physical security has to be a concern.
Speaker 3: Fair enough.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Sadly, unfortunately. All right,
that's all I had. All right, thanks very much for
the call. I appreciate that. A lot of lot of
good, good topics today. Let's go to E.J. from
the Philippines. E.J., you were on the air.
Speaker 4: Oh,
tell. It can be heard
Speaker 1: just
barely what you what was your question
today? Let's see if we can get through it.
Speaker 4: So my question is that.
And it's about the 2024 elections.
Well, I know it's a bit far
away, but I want to ask you if.
Biden won't run again in 2024.
Speaker 1: I don't know, Kamala, this
Speaker 4: hypothetical, it's
a hypothetical, Oh, OK, OK.
He won't if he won't run
again in 2010, appointed him.
I chose. Have in the nomination. Should
she think she should be primaried?
Speaker 1: No, I am not. I would never say there
should be no primary, I mean, yeah, primary if
there's a good candidate, if Joe Biden doesn't run
and Kamala runs, if somebody wants to primary her,
they absolutely should do it. I mean, I've already
said, I don't think it looks that good for Kamala
Harris if she becomes the nominee because Joe
Biden doesn't run. But there should be. We have
a system primary, whoever you want. I'm not
going to be the one saying, don't do it. No.
Speaker 4: Well, I did agree with you on that,
that will never be a good candidate to be
utterly against Trump in 2024.
Speaker 1: Well, we don't know if it will
be against Trump importantly, but I just don't
see Kamala based on her persistently low approval
rating and her lack of tangible accomplishments
so far. Still a long time to go. Of course,
it's not feeling to me like she would be a super
strong candidate in 2024, but I could be wrong. We
still got three years to go.
Speaker 4:
Fair enough, and it's just in my two cents. Yeah.
Speaker 1: LAUGHTER,
OK, good. How are things in
the Philippines otherwise OK?
But really know what's what's going on.
Speaker 4: Election year next year
and presidency, the vice presidency
and other typical positions.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's sound. You're
not a Detroit fan, it sounds like.
Speaker 4: As you know, I mean, I was I was up
first, but. In the US, he kind of lost my respect.
Speaker 1: Yeah, mine too. E.J. Thank you for
the call. I really appreciate it. All right,
very good there is E.J. from the Philippines.
We're going to take a very quick break. If you're
holding on to talk to me, don't hang up because
I'm going right back to the phones in a moment.